heidi ho rejectos we're gonna watch from
our buddy chris
over at 3c films a video of his that he
put out a week ago
and apparently to toot my own horns
because i got multiples of them
i was the first one to tell him that it
was trending on youtube oh dude you're
responsible for chris's success
i was like dude you're trending i gotta
watch this and a week later a million
views later i'm watching it
yeah i had to wait for chris to become a
citizen of these united states before
reacting to this
i don't you didn't see his twitter i
mean come on man
like that's such a na you like you would
they get everyone who's
a lot of that's such a that's too inside
all right i take it back
no you're in this one
hello space jam fans thanks so much
clicking on this video my name is chris
space jam 2 entitled space jamming new
legacy just dropped their trailer
and i just went ahead and spent so much
time diving through every frame
of this space jam and new legacy trailer
to bring you guys a good breakdown
point out easter eggs you might have
missed also help you better understand
the plot and what is going
down in this movie because some details
deep and philosophical
i need a whole ending breakdown what you
thought of the space jam 2 trailer
did it surprise you do you like the vibe
it's going for can you believe
all this madness happening in the movie
i'm also just gonna beg you
please hit that subscribe button please
hit that like button i really put my all
into this breakdown so pretty please
share it around subscribe like it just
please without further ado though
let's go ahead and get into this
breakdown because uh all these guys
right here
show up in the damn trailer all right
notification bells turn on for your
channel lebron james is playing himself
as expected the same way michael jordan
did except
it is kind of a made-up version of
himself because this actor will be
portraying his son now right away we get
a hint to something further going on in
the movie as we see the sun
is playing a basketball game on his
handheld device
and that basketball court almost exactly
resembles the court that they end up on
later on in the movie the father-son oh
how cool
lebron james that's going to come into
play to fill his potential there when
his son
is more interested in things like coding
video games
building programs and i'm sure that'll
definitely come into play when they get
sucked into a virtual world
i wonder how much of this is inspired
off of lebron james's real-life
interaction with his child
absolutely a lot of it yeah i'm sure
like i had a conflict with my kid and
this should be the plot for space jam
we don't have a script wait a minute i
got something this whole movie is to
manipulate his son
into becoming a basketball player yeah
what better way to do that than
looney tunes and everything else wbo i
don't even know if he has a kid in real
life
i don't know looking here in the
background this might be the warner
brothers headquarters and lebron james
is having a meeting most likely for some
sort of made up movie in that universe
in the background we can see marvin the
martian and what appears to be the
character of dot from the animaniacs the
animaniacs actually make a ton of
appearances in this trailer moving
forward into the stream
here at the warner brothers studios
lebron james has had his meeting
and is also having a fight with his son
about his future the elevator turns into
the letters
a g which stands for algae the name of
don cheadle's character the villain of
the film but as far as getting
into the spaceship world instead of
being true a lot of details here the way
we did in the first space jam movie with
michael jordan
we will be taken to a virtual world
where all the warner brother ip
characters live so this room right here
contains
every single movie that warner brothers
has ever made the famous old wb
server farm ralph style and following
his son lebron james gets sucked into
this warner brothers world and right
about here is where i was losing my mind
okay just gonna be listing off some of
the stuff we see here it looks like
every separate property is divided into
planets in this warner brothers server
verse so right away we get to see the
game of thrones plan
and moving on here to the wizard of oz
planet even though
it's like a little movie planet just
like a behind the scenes crew
on the right side though that is the
flintstones planet you can make out some
of the rocks
along with some dinosaurs damn chris
james gets sucked into the wizard of oz
world he gets hit with a tornado
yeah we then cut through it took me a
couple of viewings to pick that
up it's just this a.i bean that controls
all the warner brothers servers and for
some reason
only wants to give lebron james a son
back after they play
a basketball game yeah is don cheadle
part of any warner brothers movies
he's gotta be is the a.i gonna be a
version that is aware that it's taking
on the appearance of don
cheadle i hope so and it's space jam the
first one
part of like like in lebron james world
will his son have a copy of the movie
space jam
this will be michael jordan right the
human centipede two of spades this will
be the human centipede of the space jam
they'll be like i love that original
space jam movie we need to recreate it
that's a good button now we can go back
to the reaction absolutely
a lot of sense but whatever this movie's
already looking awesome enough the rules
for the basketball game seem pretty
simple lebron james has a couple of
hours to round up his team members algae
decides to start him off
in search of his team members in the
tune world now when this sign spins we
get to see some of the other
worlds neptune hogwarts already notice
all that neptune
mars and even hogwarts so yes the harry
potter world exists in here
probably the part i enjoyed the most
right here is lebron james being thrown
into the tune world the shift of music i
think it's also sounding pretty great
they're not only doing callbacks to
previous songs
in the first space jam movie by kind of
remixing them they are also throwing in
iconic looney tune sounds immediately
when put into the tune world though
lebron james becomes 2d animated the way
he should be
giving us a mix of both worlds where he
finally gets to meet
bugs bunny we're then finally
what i've been waiting for his whole
career planets they pass through here
the maltese falcons
here is the gotham city planet which
actually seems to be
oh where's metropolis oh like bbs
because you can definitely see the
difference in the daylight where one is
gotham city and one is a little more
cleaner looking so that's that's cool
metropolis
next up lebron james seeming to
understand that he can only pick
warner brothers characters for his team
starts listing off people he knows now
he's got here
superman as his number one choice
gandalf
king kong and he's about to write down
iron giant
the best part of after this list though
is just the look
bugs bunny gives to lebron james like
boy
you really think superman gonna be in
our we can't even guess man of steel two
how we gotta get superman in space jam
too
yeah i'm wondering if in that bit if
they'll start naming off characters who
are not
warner brothers property would they be
allowed to get away with that they'd be
able to get away with that right they'd
be allowed to be like
can we get iron man not owned by you
know some joke like that
i feel like gold gold comedy right there
comedy gold best
plus golden comedy that's what people
coming to space jam really want is is
meta references
to the ownership of rights by other
studios
again great button yes transitions so
good
transitioning wise also worth noting
that he's wearing marvin the martian's
helmet which lets us know that's what
they're traveling in throughout this
movie viciously conquered marvel they
seem to have hijacked
marvin the martian spaceship so that
they can travel to these different
warner brother ip locations
bugs bunny seems to get a little bit
realistic with lebron james and tells
him that the people we need
are the people who have already won a
basketball game in the first space jam
movie
rounding up the looney tunes squad now
here's some backstory yeah it was all of
them the trailer doesn't really let you
know
it wasn't michael jordan have decided to
live on different planets
have separate lives with each other and
a main part of this movie will be to
round up all the looney tunes characters
make amends oh really
how we see some of these different
planets like we heard from the director
lola
i love that mascara
living on the mad max planet that might
be the roadrunner cause he seems like
you're running fast everywhere they even
mentioned a deleted scene of pepe le pew
who was originally supposed to be part
of this team
hiding away in the casablanca movie
planet
really would love to hear some of your
guys's guesses to where you think some
of these looney tunes characters will be
hiding in the movie and where they have
to go find them
well clearly yosemite
is hiding out in
in westworld
yeah it works yeah because cowboy is
cowboy and you know
i thought we were going to land on
something way funnier
failed then we were like what westerns
does wbo
like uh hogwarts that sounds stupid and
this didn't go well
keep this all in the video it's gonna
gets in it
it's in the video but hey it's okay we
got droogs to make up for pepe le pew we
got
every kid's favorite movie a clockwork
orange [ __ ] here
that's true i thought this would have
ended better if
we had edited if we'd done the first one
earlier and then and then you
went with the juice i'm going to keep
this out of the dress i think the cut
would have been
are going to be mentioned okay it looks
like it doesn't take them that long to
round up all the toon squad characters
because they have them here in training
a scene that we are very familiar with
that happen in the first space jam movie
i love how lola is part of the coaching
side of this training like yeah
i'm a real player let's show you guys
how to do this another interesting thing
worth noting that's just some fun trivia
in the space jam world
yosemite sam here is having his guns and
is shooting them off there's a big
controversy when the new looney tunes
cartoon was rebooted on hbo max and they
took away his guns
in the movie it looks like that won't be
a problem at all in this next shot here
it becomes
so lola bunny's gotta change her her
outfit around
yeah but yosemite can fire off some guns
yes yeah yeah because in america that's
okay we love we love violence but we
cannot handle sex
sexuality of any kind even if it's just
a figure you're a
bunny not a [ __ ] yes you
painted lady of the night and they took
away his guns
in the movie it looks like that won't be
a problem at all and this next shot here
it becomes pretty clear that once they
move planet to planets
so hbo max is coming for her gun
liberal hollywood animated to a
realistic 3d
look and one thing i'm surprised made it
into this movie is the classic
toon squad jerseys you see right here
bugs bunny
is wearing the same jerseys from the
very first space jam film so that kind
of lets us know
the first space jam movie did happen in
their universe whether it was
a movie that these looney tune
characters were acting
in or it was an event that really
happened for them and it's something
they remembered
if this is in the middle i hope it's
just a movie i hope it's
to see the jerseys there these next
couple of shots go by super fast so i'm
just gonna list off the characters that
appear on screen
starting off here the mystery machine
yeah the mystery machine which is the
scooby-doo
van we even see scooby-doo popping out
his head a little bit in this trailer
only for it then to
immediately cut to the iron giant i love
anytime i get to see the iron giants one
of my favorite
childhood movies this film is all just
pure nostalgia
it's interesting though that iron giant
is in this film when he also showed up
in ready player one and that was a
universal movie so
man the iron giant can't get a sequel
but he sure loves the cameo
is that hurting your feelings is they're
all about iron giant right that's one of
your favorite movies
yeah i'm actually not as bothered by
this as i was by ready player one
because ready player one the whole point
is like ah we're fighting to you know uh
grasp this empire and you know it's in
the guise of a big
war whereas this is about basketball
like i don't think the same rule of i am
not a gun applies to just like
fun competitive sports i think you're a
little sensitive about your fake
properties but i
you know what this is a travesty i will
be starting a petition
so look out for that and sign it you're
allowed to feel however you want
one of the buildings we catch here in
the background says evil scientists this
is a reference to a popular building
that would show up in
looney tunes cartoons that would have
this little green evil scientist
responsible
for making a gosmer a member of the team
cutting to more shops this video taught
me that character's name ones i found
that i could list off here
is mega gorilla on his little unicycle
yogi bear
and boo boo flintstone characters with
fred
wilma barney we also have the jetsons in
their flying car
in the background captain caveman flying
into frame
another classic cartoon yeah yeah i was
going to say undercat's character
in the background here pretty funny how
much did this movie cost
from the godzilla vs kong director that
appears to be the character of chitara
they even go ahead and throw in some
newer
lesser known characters in their movies
like this is a character from
an animated film called small foot that
didn't perform
all that well
here in the bottom frame you also have
penelope pit stop in her iconic car here
that is a dick dastardly character
my boy king kong coming in afterwards
godzilla these are the iconic planes
that king kong
faces off in his movie the next frame
here is where i start really geeky now
because there's some characters i'm more
familiar with we have
algae the villain played by don chido
but right behind him we have
an agent from the matrix movies you also
have
someone being an imposter of martin
luther king mr princess mr freeze
an evil monkey from the wizard of oz
even pennywise the clown
we knew petty blaze the clown would be
in the movie i hope we get to pop into
the stephen king or pennywise world in
these next couple of seconds
they'll do a whole sequence inside the
shining
characters here but i'm going to try and
list off as many as i can oh my god
you're insane don't do this
you have space ghosts there again you
have mega gorillas scooby doo characters
even good old velma
yogi bear the dinosaur from the
flintstones whenever fred gets off work
even an upscale reference right here to
frankenstein jr
and buzz conroy another shot here of
penelope pit stop in her car
really you could be spending hours
zooming into all
the characters in the past well do it
yeah chris what we pay you for is if you
look at the scoreboard
it says followers 834 000. and that's
because
a big plot contention in this movie is
that the main goal algae has
if lebron james loses the basketball
game
is algae gets to keep all of lebron
james's instagram phone
i'm not making that up that is happening
that's part of the space jam movie
they're fine for instagram followers i'm
happy okay
probably my second favorite shot from
this trailer is the two squad here in an
avengers style lineup a couple things to
notice though in this shot
one wiley coyote is number 13. i think
that's pretty funny because
unlucky number 13 and wiley coyote is
just known for being this character
whose traps backfire on him whenever
he's trying to go after the roadrunner
happy duck here in a suit now it's being
said daffy duck might actually play the
coach
of the team or sort of like the owner of
the toon squad that's why he's
in a suit but we've also seen him in a
jersey and other promotional work so it
might be a big thing
that he steps on into the game at the
end of it to save everybody
also because he's really small and you
might miss him you have here speedy
gonzales brothers
oh dude
really my favorite addition to this team
is just the character of gosma right
there in the background just that giant
red boy looking awesome and next shot
here we're introduced to the villain
team for the space jam movie these are
known as the goon squad and they're
gonna be made
up of members from the nba and wnba in
the previous movie they were made up of
spaceships yeah just given these
monster-like abilities
here it's kind of going to be the same
thing but each character has their own
unique characteristic we have here
a falcon eagle looking one a player that
seems to be a robot with electricity
powers
another player here resembling a snake a
spider
which basketball players are they yeah
what styles are they going to emulate
water abilities
and of course yeah these are the
elements
it's also worth noting that in the
background of this robot doing his thing
you get to see
here the 1989 jumper he's even standing
to some members from the mad max movie
you even have two catwomans next to each
other one from the 60s tv series and
michelle
pfeiffer from the 1989 movie we are then
treated to some action shots within the
game
what i've been loving about what we've
been seeing at least is that a lot of
the characters are cgi
implemented but then a lot of them are
actually put in actual costumes and
makeup
i don't know how many of them are going
to get close-ups i don't know how many
of them are only going to be just in the
background obviously but i really do
appreciate that
for a lot of these characters that are
actually going out of their way to do
makeup
yeah and putting actual blending the
green screen with some actual actors to
sell the effect
it's important in a space jam movie to
to do that yeah yeah man
yeah yeah yeah we are then treated to
some action shots within the game now i
haven't played basketball in a minute
here with this belly but i don't
remember the last time you had to shoot
up into the scoreboard
gonna be interesting what kind of rules
are in play in this space jam game this
feels like it's just going to be the
highlight of the movie seeing the toon
squad come together put their hands all
in that pile and go off against the goon
squad
other things we could spot here in the
background are popular monuments from
cartoons like we have the acme rocket
duck rogers is spaceship now a surprise
member of the goon squad will
actually be lebron james like shaking
their christmas movie
that's supposed to be a graphic players
trailer lebron james called his son very
talented on the court so this is just a
way to spite his father into going like
fine you call me a star player
i'll play against you but at the end day
i still want to be my own person another
beautiful oh
wow there's so many so personal this is
about to leap
into a dunk starting off left to right
here we get two
two penguins the noah's ark of
characters
jim carries the mask mr freeze behind
him along with another agent even
pennywise they're still standing then
as we move along with some other game of
thrones characters we also get to see
the joker from the 60s batman series
right there i was hoping to find joaquin
phoenix's joker because he's said to be
in here as well
but there's even more characters that i
can barely get what you deserved
it's also worth noting that they use the
scoob designs from the most recent
animated movie for the scooby-doo
characters
in this movie on this left side here we
have the animaniacs tower you even have
froghorn leg horns barn house
from his cartoon series moving on to
lebron james doing a dunk
cutting to lola bunny giving you a wink
and right there
in love with the new lola bunny my
favorite shop of the trailer
hands down lebron james does over
calculate that jump and end up on the
floor
leading to tweety saint classic and the
reason he says that is because this is a
callback to the first space jam movie
where michael jordan did the exact same
thing and tweety bird was flying around
his head
giving us here an ending gag for the
trailer we have some clockwork orange
characters
more mad max characters game of thrones
characters you also have blue falcon and
dinoma here in the background
and as granny is doing her three-point
shot with a senior discount we also get
to see
the 60s robin right there and that
trailer to me was absolutely bonkers
fans they're like mainly get the batman
franchise in here yep
everyone loves batman it looks like it's
gonna be so much fun and they said
they're wanting to make this franchise
so
we could see more things in the future
the looney tunes returning
let me know if there were any easter
eggs or characters in the backgrounds
that i might have missed that you guys
went ahead and caught there are so many
might have missed missed a bunch of
people but be sure to leave me your
thoughts down below don't forget to like
and subscribe
follow me on twitter at 3c film review
as always i'm chris
take care
it wants to make it a franchise i think
i think it is a franchise
it's now a franchise that there's a part
two it is now
franchise yeah now we gotta get part
three green lit
that's if if i was a commentator chris
that is
all i would say after all your editing
all of your hard drive and
hard work i would be like it's already a
franchise that'd be my only feedback
yeah you totally missed the point here
yeah dude dislike
unsubscribe chris i'm proud of you buddy
this video got to a million views so
fast and i see why
i care significantly to check out this
video to find out what all the easter
eggs are i
don't care enough about this movie to
discover what they are for myself
yeah on my own time but i am proud of
you
for putting in the time and effort
insane and nutty
and i am looking forward to this movie i
think it's going to be a really really
great time
with some dramatic story beats that
don't seem entirely necessary
but we'll do just enough of the job to
make it a little bit
more zesty more impactful
more of a character study guys subscribe
to 3c films if you haven't done so
already
or as i call them chris hit that like
button
check us out on youtube all right see
you guys
[Music]